hi i'm sandra bullock and i'm jenny
tatum and this is the wired autocomplete
interview and we'd love you to go see
lost city in theaters march 25th
[Music]
feel and ask that's what this game is
stop being such a peeling ass
[Music]
[Applause]
what channing tatum maybe it's a
question they're like what
what channing tate what does channing
tatum smell like oh it's like
frankincense and myrrh today
very
earthy
spicy kind of christmasy kind of smell
okay
what was channing tatum's first movie
step up oh no
that's the first one i saw havoc was my
very first movie barbara koppel directed
it and hathaway
mike vogel um no no one asked any of
those questions i'm just saying i just
wanted to announce i just wanted you to
know google this that i was in the movie
that's how i proved that i technically
was in the movie i knew stuff about it
okay anyway there's a lot of nothing
what song does channing tatum dance to
in magic mike pony pony pony pony pony i
tried to play that once when he got
angry at me i did not get angry you
caught sophie i might have given you a
dance well they might have that's if
that's the dance you might have you're
filming it's an angry dance angry laptop
you're angry what music videos is
channing tatum in i haven't the
slightest idea
uh my very first job ever was a ricky
martin video
stop you know he's my neighbor no way
like two houses away you're in a ricky
martial i was in she bangs you weren't
as i was i was bartender with a like a
face paint like in a mohawk okay i
didn't know that i'm kind of like
fangirling a little bit it's kind of
great it was great it was great
does sandra bullock get rescued in
gravity no she rescues herself she
rescues yourself but i guess you would
have to get rescued off of the beach you
didn't see that happen no one know what
rescued her she wasn't she died on the
beach she got herself up and started
walking for help so she took care of
herself so no she did not get rescued i
co-signed this did sandra bullock have a
crush on keanu yes
big time whoa that's common knowledge
that is is it we actually just recently
admitted it admitted it did it
we've recently admitted it did you guys
ever date nope never once
oh
is sandra bullock a leo i don't know the
answers because i don't know your actual
birthday but i'm gonna say you are leo
yeah
yeah characteristically i'm told that
i'm i'm very
loud and i like to get in everyone's
stuff like
but yeah i guess i am i guess i am they
have a lot of hair and i have a lot of
hair
can sandra bullock sing no not at all
her father was a uh
a voice teacher voice teacher who's an
opera singer i cannot sing they say it
skips a generation my daughter can sing
beautifully
so
she's got the pipes all right is
channing tatum
funny am i supposed to answer this
i don't know i'm funny-looking i think
he's [ __ ] hilarious it's channing
tatum and coach carter yes yes lyle
is channing tatum a nice guy when he
responds i i'm bad over
i am texts nice guys let me tell you
guys how nice i am oh my god is channing
tatum his real name is channing a family
name uh no actually weirdly my dad was
like a roofer my mom worked at like a
bank neither one of them were artists i
was like y'all just decided to kind of
go that's like my sister gazina vanessa
bullock is gazina like german is that
like a
it was a beautiful poem that my mother
loved and i said she goes i just
couldn't remember it when you were born
i said so you picked sandra what sandra
bullock what sandra bullock character
are you i am uh her character from
practical magic sally sally
yeah what movie is sandra bullock and
ryan reynolds
the proposal yeah the proposal yeah
we're the proposal i almost called it
the the internals the internet same
thing
with with the intern what did sandra
bullock get an oscar for
lightsai mindset what sorority was
sandra bullock sandra bullock was not in
a sorority
channing tatum it's just chatting to me
was channing tatum a wrestler
you weren't not in high school or like
in a real competitive sense no i played
played one in a in a movie yeah he was
so good in that movie fox catcher
where's channing tatum from columbin
alabama is where i was born but i was
raised in uh mississippi and in tampa i
play from alabama in this movie called
fighting but i haven't really done like
a southern southern movie i've played in
west virginia which is not where i'm
from but yeah who is channing tatum's
best friend
sandra bullock
i guess my best friend is my creative
partner reed carolyn you guys make a
nice team who is channing tatum and
x-men unfortunately i'm not an x-man
very tragically just like i wasn't in a
sorority what yep the sandra bullock
have a tattoo yes she does
not that i've seen prove it yeah
i got you i have one and my tattoo
artist will uh verify okay
who's your fuji tattooers
well then how am i gonna verify this
okay got it i'll call and get reference
would you does sandra bullock own a
restaurant yes
i think you might own more than one i
had two at one time yeah austin texas
what's it called it's called walton's
fancy and staple does sandra bullock die
in speed no no
definitely not annie survives speed two
is i don't even want to call that a
speed
let's call that a medium to slow did
sandra bullock play the piano i bet you
she would say no uh but i think that she
could play a little i took lessons yes
12 years hated every minute of it
so
how much can channing tatum bench 325
i don't think i ever really no benching
wasn't my thing i didn't want a big
chest i think the most i ever got was
like 255 for 10 and i i don't know now i
just go really light in a lot of reps
yeah how many tattoos do channing tatum
have one
two
three four now nothing on your legs oh i
just got a little one i did one five uh
five got one with the ranger boys oh
yeah how many times has channing tatum
been on
bear grylls two times uh and the last
one was in norway and i got to jump out
of a helicopter whenever bear calls i
know i'm gonna get to do something i've
never done before so bear's a legend as
well you ever done that show no
you might you might should do that show
i might should not you might should i
might should just stay home and watch it
i think you would be really good on the
show i should like to stay home i think
you'd be one entertaining and i think
you would don't want that kind of
entertainment i like your safety at my
home would you go on with me no why you
know i'm gonna take care of you and
we're gonna laugh a lot why can't we
just have a dinner i'll bring you a
mama's helper how about that
oh you see our chicken oh hold on sing
it mama's helper is going to be there
why sandra bullock why sandra pulling
why did sonja
east carolina university greenville
north carolina because uh my best friend
in high school had an application and i
didn't want to be forced to go to a
school of the arts like my dad went to
because i wasn't ready and i did not
have the talent is sandra bullock fluent
in german yeah
where was your mother born in known bag
nun
why does sandra bullock not have
instagram because she's the only smart
one here
because she's too scared i'm just too
scared
smart why was sandra bullock on george
lopez because i produced a george lopez
show any chance i got to be um accident
amy on the george lopez show i took it
that's cool yeah i think it brought him
such great pleasure to see like a hammer
hit my head and you stand back
oh george yeah oh george
no more questions no more questions
tis all how do you say that's all in
german this is alice this is alice yeah
soccer peterson
[Music]